all right odd to this omicron has taken
the spotlight this new year's eve as
caseloads nationwide are surpassing get
this
january 2021 levels now we know omicron
is more mild however the caseload is
particularly high meanwhile president
biden what's he doing he's spending the
holiday at his beach house it's his 31st
trip there but his admin his
administration is urging the supreme
court to keep his vaccine mandate on
private companies the same one by the
way that is helping cause the worker
shortage but that aside members of
congress meanwhile are saying it's time
to block the vaccine mandate i would
happen to agree with them lawrence and
joey jones
it's pretty remarkable the way that this
president has abused his authority he
used osha a very little used regulation
to seize on emergency power in a way
that's never been done
to create this onerous vaccine mandate
on the american people you know i was
looking into a national review article
on the likelihood of the supreme court
upholding this
and just this july get this the
congressional research service said this
about that osha provision he used for
his vaccine mandate they said that this
has rarely been used this authority in
the past and it's not been used since
the courts get this struck down in
asbestos similar related order in 1983
so in other words the last time this
provision was used was
1983 and the court struck it down so
biden has really exceeded his authority
and guys caused a lot of economic pain
and hardship in doing so lawrence
you know kaylee i gotta tell you i i
continue to be baffled by the
administration response to cova
especially when you had the president of
the united states
just telling us days ago that he was
against a federal response now we know
what the courts have been doing the
entire time the courts have been
striking down all these federal mandates
they simply said that they they just
can't do it they don't have the
authority to do it they cited it a
little bit more when it comes to states
and local governments but on the federal
level they have not been favorable to
the biden administration uh bill bennett
with our fox news contributor former
education secretary said
he predicts that there's going to be a
great relearning in response to the
covet
response watch
this may be the educational shake-up we
need but i do think the great relearning
is beginning i think it's beginning in
earnest when you talk to people around
the country citizens
those subjects are becoming citizens to
use your nice phrase there
i think you can see sign of this and
people are tired of surrendering to the
experts
who have been so wrong
just one last thing when the when the
head of cdc says well we thought ten
days
uh for lockup uh you know uh would be
proper but we decided to go with five
because we think that's all that the
public could bear
well
that ain't science that's policy
that ain't science that's policy you
know what it is it's politics is what it
is we don't need bureaucrats making
decisions that we elected politicians
for you know lawrence you said you're
baffled by this i'm beyond baffled by it
we have a president who got elected in
the office with this big pitch on
coronavirus and how he was the savior
and we saw this week just how unprepared
this administration is i hope that you
know for the sake of this country i hope
they get their stuff together and start
making forward-looking decisions
no doubt about it you know president
biden said it's time to shut down the
virus he promised us he'd do so but it
really feels like covid um in many ways
has shut us down it's very much
unfortunate i went to brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now